this is Startalk debbie large wants to
know why isn't there more news coverage
of science advancement when I was a kid
all networks had a science correspondent
that's true what the hell well now
there's a whole channel called the
Science Channel
yeah but why not yeah but that's for
people already like science or want to
watch toilets get built and how it works
at a factory what about like whatever
like good like NBC what about major
networks being like this is the weather
and this is today's science I guess I
guess it doesn't sell well enough or
else a would have it yeah there's other
sources for that information mostly
online we recommend planetary door guy
just did a fabulous thing with IFLS I
won't spell that out just go check it
out because they it's the news of
science I think it could be I think it's
a shame that it's not seen as a more
interesting topic or maybe more
entertaining the three levels yeah we
need to that's what we're trying to do
now is what I agree it should be more in
the mainstream okay I think it could be
I think so